ماذا يحدث للجسم بعد الموت سؤال مثير
وجدلي والاجابه عنه يحاول العلماء التوصل
اليها منذ فتره طويله جدا او حتى الكشف عن
جزء بسيط منها الجديد في هذا الموضوع هو
ان تقريرا طبيا نشره موقع وستبتو هيلث
الامريكي اوضح خضوع الجسم لتعديلات عده
ناتجه عن تغييرات مبكره ومتاخره بعد
اللحظه التي يتم فيها اطفاء ضوء الحياه
فالمبكره تحدث بعد 24 ساعه من الوفاه
وفيها يصبح الجلد شاحبا ثم يبدا توزيع
الدم بالجاذبيه على اجزاء الجسم الاقرب
الى الارض كما يفقد الجسم حرارته الطبيعيه
لدواء كما تعلمون فان البروده هي علامه
مميزه للموت وفي الساعات الاولى ايضا تبدا
كل عضلات الجسم في الاسترخاء ونتيجه لذلك
تصبح مفاصل الجسم مرنه وتفقد الجفون لون
ويميل الفك الى الانفتاح اما التغييرات
المتاخره فتحدث بعد 24 الى 36 ساعه من
حدوث الوفاه وفيها تتم عمليه تدمير
التدريجي للاعضاء والانسجه وتشمل ايضا
التحلل الذاتي او الهضم الذاتي ثم التعفن
الذي يحدث نتيجه اغلاق جهاز المناعه
وحينها يمكن للبكتيريا ان تنتشر بحريه الى
جميع انسجه الجسم